(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
♪ Whoo ♪
♪ Keep the snow and sleigh rides ♪
♪ Keep those silver bells ♪
♪ Keep the gifts beneath the tree ♪
♪ Give them to someone else ♪
♪ Keep that magic snowman ♪
♪ Keep those twinkly lights ♪
♪ Keep the reindeer ♪
♪ My heart already knows how to fly ♪
♪ 'Cause all I ever wanted ♪
♪ Was nothing I got, and ♪
♪ Santa, can't you hear me ♪
♪ Oh-oh, oh-oh ♪
♪ I don't need a thing ♪
♪ I sent a letter to you, ooh, ooh ♪
♪ On how to make my dreams
come true, oh yeah ♪
♪ Keep the mistletoe ♪
♪ Unless below ♪
♪ Is what I need ♪
♪ Oh, Santa, can't you hear me ♪
♪ 'Cause all I ever wanted ♪
♪ Was nothing I got, and ♪
♪ Santa, can't you hear me ♪
♪ 'Cause one thing that I need ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ What I want for Christmas ♪
♪ Hasn't come and I've been so good ♪
♪ Tell me what can I do, ooh, ooh ♪
♪ Oh yeah ♪
♪ Keep the mistletoe ♪
♪ Unless below ♪
♪ Is what I need ♪
♪ Oh, Santa, can't you hear me ♪
(audience cheering)